welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and El Camino is the Breaking Bad
epilogue following Jesse Pinkman in the
days following the finale episode the
slow burn Western that doesn't aim to
fix or revise anything about Vince
Gilligan's perfect ending but rather a
more conclusive end to an open ending
for a guy who loved saying [ __ ] [ __ ]
this film contained a number of
significant tie-ins with Breaking Bad
cameos subtle callbacks meaningful
symbols I'm gonna quickly break down all
of these Easter eggs extinction of
Easter eggs and spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the movie yet Shh okay the
film opens on a flashback with Mike
Ehrmantraut set in season five when
Jesse and Mike decided to leave Walt's
meth business after all the dark turns
with shooting kid witnesses working with
neo-nazis this is the same Riverside
where shortly after this meeting with
Jesse Walt shot Mike and where Mike died
while watching this water flow passed
for both Mike and Jesse this must have
been one of their final moments of
freedom when they still thought that
they could cut ties with Walt peacefully
here they discussed where to go next
and Mike suggests yeah Bible your age
starting fresh Alaska the last frontier
at the end of the film this is actually
where Jesse ends up and actually some
time ago Aaron Paul gave Alaska as an
answer to his ideal destiny for Jesse
during a reddit AMA Jesse hopes that
he'll finally be able to put things
right after retiring but Mike responds
no so I kid that's one thing you can
never do this line serves as a kind of
meta promise for this el camino film the
past is in the past Jesse can't write
any past wrongs and this movie can't
change anything from the Breaking Bad
finale and it doesn't want to it's only
about opening up and suggesting a future
chapter if you watch better call Saul
which you should it's amazing it
explores Mike's backstory as a grieving
father of a cop son who was killed as
part of a corruption deal gone bad mike
has been able to change that dark past
by being overprotective now so he warns
Jesse to not worry about the past and
blaze a new path with a fresh start we
jump to the present day Jesse's fleeing
Jack's compound screening drumming the
steering-wheel evades police and makes
it to the home of badger and skinny Pete
now you can look at Jesse's return here
as kind of a resurrection of Christ his
body is covered in lashing scars Pete
and Badger are doubting Thomases
initially not recognizing Jesse but tree
with this kind of reverence they adore
him as a hero they give him for
everything they have to him like Jesus
Jesse's humanity comes from his
suffering now in this pseudo resurrected
state his journey in this film is that
of a ghost trying to transition from one
light to the next while in Pete's room
there's a moment where Jesse looks up at
the ceiling to see the smoke detector
seeing it triggers him to roll out of
bed the shot is just like the final
image of the famous fly episode of
Breaking Bad in which the Walt and Jesse
are haunted by a literal fly in their
aunt Marie's nted the lingering issues
between them and Walt's inability to
just move forward the fly continued to
haunt Walt in the final shot of that
episode its silhouette flashing briefly
on the red light and the smoke detector
similarly Jesse here has unfinished
business he doesn't want to end up like
Walt and interesting Lee other pests
continue to play a major symbolic roles
in this movie jesse calls old joe from
the scrapyard and attempt to disposed as
el camino' as they previously used him
to dispose the RV's over calls the
season 5 premiere episode when he hooked
them up with that super magnet to
destroy evidence
but the El Camino registers and police
system so Joe bounces leaving badger
Pete and Jesse to swap cars to split up
Todd and the psychopath Jesse Plemons
returns via flash back to Jesse's
imprisonment Todd makes Jesse help him
move the body of his cleaning lady after
she found Todd's hidden cache cache that
Jesse now needs
Todd's apartment has a few terrifying
Easter eggs
he kept as a pet that tarantula caught
by drew sharp the kid on the dirt bike
that he murdered the way that that
tarantula was entombed in a jar
foreshadowed the way Todd and Wald's
disposed of that kid and now Todd
creepily keeps it almost as a kind of
trophy now there's a second creepy
Easter egg in his apartment but before I
continued thanks to honey for sponsoring
this episode
you provide something online and then
find out that you could have gotten it
for less if you just knew the right
discount you kind of feel like a Jesse
Pinkman always missing out on the easy
option always one foot in a porta potty
luckily there's honey the free browser
extension that in the click of one
button scans the internet for coupon
codes and automatically applies the best
one to your cart at checkout honey knows
about every coupon code sale discount on
over 20,000 sites like Amazon eBay
Target Game Stop Best Buy it's got how
all the scoops and you can just shop
like normal and honey's got you back
there doing all the work in the
background to save you that money honey
has successfully applied 185 million
working coats to people's orders last
year and my subscribers who have
downloaded honey of our
he's saved over a hundred thousand bucks
you can be one of them I went on Newegg
to buy some parts for my computer and I
saved a hundred ten dollars fifty nine
cents savings that I will use to buy a
keyboard that doesn't have an e missing
you know you pop that out by hitting
shift e for hi I'm Erik Bosse at the
start of hundreds of videos it's been a
real problem where as I write it
probably honey installation is super
easy just go to join honey calm slash
new rock stars and two clicks later
there you go honey's for everyone
because it works for practically
anything you buy online downloading it
as easy just takes two clicks to install
there's really no reason not to use
honey it's free to use and you can
install it on your computer in just two
clicks join honey for free at join honey
calm slash new rock stars that's join
honey calm slash new rock stars thanks
again honey for sponsoring this episode
okay back to Todd's creepy apartment
later we see that he also keeps a custom
snow globe featuring a figurine of
himself and it looks like Lydia sitting
on a tea cup for her obsession with tea
and stevia the stevia that Walt poisoned
gets a nod in this film there's a news
report of Walter White's latest victim a
Houston woman in the hospital who
probably wouldn't survive
Jesse eventually finds Todd's hidden
cash inside the fridge door ranked as
two men arrived whom he thinks they're
cops but it really just looters after
this in cash that Jesse is one is Neil
Candy the welder who rigged up the
harness and wire at imprisoned Jesse in
Jack's meth lab with Todd and Kenny
returning the flashback Neil is played
by Scott MacArthur who plays a similar
pastured in the righteous gemstones on
HBO Jesse gets away with the third of
the cash but that is enough for Edie
mister disappear who demands payment for
both this relocation and the one that
Jesse bailed on in season five while
talking with Jesse he refers to his
former boss and his lawyer and relocated
Walt to New Hampshire and Saul to Omaha
where Saul can be seen working in the
Cinnabon and various flash-forwards
throughout the series better call Saul
jesse steals guns from his parents and
tracks down Neil and his buddies as they
celebrate while casing the place Jesse
finds this beetle this is a callback to
that moment in season two in the
peekaboo episode which opened with Jesse
meeting with skinny Pete briefly
touching this beetle by his feet before
Pete just crushed it there's a moment
that revealed Jesse's gentle nature how
he doesn't want to kill unless he has to
and how much it really crushes him to do
that similarly Jesse doesn't enter that
building guns a-blazing he simply asks
Neil for just 1,800 the exact amount of
money that he needs to
just disappear and get out of this mess
but Neil challenges Jessie to a
western-style quick-draw which Jesse
wins by having a second gun hidden in
his other pocket it's old calm demeanor
here with a literal trick up his sleeve
seems a lot like the kind of move he
would pick up from waltz both the time
Walt confronted to go at season one and
when he confronted Jack's gang in season
five to save Jesse so by killing Neil
Jessie is able to find another breath of
redemption achieving revenge against a
man who literally built the mechanism of
his slavery knowing what it would be
used for and continuing to laugh it off
in Jesse's face after Jesse blows up the
place
flashback takes us back a few years
earlier when Jesse was on an overnight
cook trip with her Walt with Bryan
Cranston returning for a cameo in this
hotel room Jesse's on the phone with a
girlfriend you miss me yeah this is most
likely Jane setting this moment in
season to a shot of their RV parked
outside has it taped over bullet holes
from the pilot episode so in al cafe
Jesse lets off the one pitch of this
film at the salad bar won't ask some
about his future looks out the window
pondering you're really lucky you didn't
have to wait your whole life to do
something special it's a sad moment that
reveals how Walt looked at a lifetime of
happiness building a family as a waste
but this memory teaches Jesse that
whatever unhappy life he has lived so
far he liked Walt's can always read to
find himself and find a new purpose and
live on in a brand new life under his
own terms
Edie brings Jesse to Alaska where Jesse
hands him a letter to mail if you look
closely you can see it's addressed to
Brock Andrea's Sun so as Jesse drives
off he recalls a trip he took with Jane
Krysten Ritter returning for a cameo
when she corrected an earlier statement
now it's a callback to her line at the
beginning of the flashback that opened
the season 3 episode when they went to
the Georgia O'Keeffe museum you open
yourself up and go with the flow
wherever the universe takes you now Jane
applies a new meaning to that statement
it was being metaphorical to Terra new
philosophy and now Jesse moves forward
with a purpose driving off into the
Alaskan frontier the final image creates
this elegant symmetry with Jesse's final
shot in Felina before he screamed loudly
as he drove off into the nighttime
desert covered a bill now he calmly
cruises in clean comfortable clothes in
the morning snow what do you think about
Camino as
Breaking Bad epilogue comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at a box and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching
couch I'm sorry you're not a [ __ ] yeah
I shouldn't use that word
[Music]